this has been an unprecedented election
especially when considering a number of
people
that voted before polling day many of
them
by post and now a federal judge in
washington dc
has ordered a sweep of 12 postal
districts
in a bid to track down undelivered
mail-in ballots
the u.s postal service estimates that
around 300
000 ballots it's processed have not
actually been scanned
at ballot counting locations voters
rights activists
say slow delivery is plaguing some key
swing districts
they say some ballots could be sitting
uncounted at postal facilities
around the country well kristen salumi
joins us live now from
pittsburgh so there are concerns that
some ballots may be
overlooked which could potentially be
really important tell us more
yes in philadelphia pennsylvania where i
am is one of those districts where the
judge
ordered a sweep to look for those
missing ballots
you have to remember that there is an
unprecedented number of mail-in ballots
being requested for this election and
uh this is something new as a result of
the coronavirus people voting by mail
and changes to many states
election systems allowing them to do so
here in pennsylvania
three million mail-in ballots have been
requested
about three-quarters of them have been
returned
but the state does not allow those
ballots to be counted
until election day starting on election
day and some counties have said that
they will not even begin to start
counting them until tomorrow
so this has been an issue for president
trump who's called the legitimacy of
those ballots into question
and he's also questioned
another state court ruling here in
pennsylvania which
allows the boat votes to be accepted up
to three days after the election
he said that that's something that
shouldn't be allowed he's made a big
complaint about this said it will lead
to violence and so on but
you know i have to say there's been a
lot of enthusiasm here among voters
the polling station behind me is a bit
quiet now but people had lined up
early in the day before the place
opened up and i spoke to some of the
voters out there and they said they came
out specifically
because of those concerns and wanted to
make sure that their votes are indeed
counted
have a listen to what they said because
of what trump is threatening to do
with any of the mail-in votes that are
being counted later i wanted to do my
part to contribute to
the live vote and make sure to push up
numbers for biden that's literally why i
decide to vote live
i have my absentee ballot that never
opened with me just going to turn that
in in front
i think it's important now more than
ever so many people are hurting
uh this pandemic has caused so much
stress uh loss and
depression and anxiety and everything
and uh
this is the one day that we can at least
pump some light into this universe
and uh just holding up my torch
lots of enthusiasm among voters we heard
from some
biden supporters there i've heard from
trump's supporters here in pennsylvania
as well yesterday we were about an hour
outside of philadelphia and there was a
line
in bucks county outside the election
office there of people who
had requested mail-in ballots and didn't
get it or perhaps had
had some issue with their mail and
ballot including one woman who drove
13 hours because she didn't receive her
mail-in ballot and wanted to vote for
president trump
so a lot of enthusiasm on both sides but
we may not know who comes out ahead here
in pennsylvania for several days the
governor here and other officials are
warning people to be patient
for those results to come in chris and
salumi joining us live
from pittsburgh pennsylvania with that
development kristen thank you